this is a special shout out to all the
musicians who are watching my channel
every week on sunday i do a compilation
of famous entrepreneurs and share their
stories quickly and the the failures
that they had to overcome in the end the
little man who didn't believe in them
and i put these together as a short clip
usually between one and two minutes and
i have this background music that's
playing and i have it on there because
i'm not much musician and and i can't
create great songs myself and i can with
the idea of why don't i work with
talented musicians who are watching this
channel and give them some exposure
because those videos get views and I
want to help promote your music so if
you watch any of those videos they
usually come out on a Sunday the famous
failure ones what I'd love to do is have
your music be the background track for
those videos and maybe we could feature
a different musician each time we put on
new video and I can link to your
soundtrack in the description of the
video I really want to help other
entrepreneurs these musicians I want to
help you get more exposure get more
well-known and provide some inspiring
soundtrack for the video as well so if
you guys are interested you can shoot me
a message or leave a comment below with
a link to your YouTube channel and we'll
take it from there believe